at first glance everything looks the
same but a new era may have begun in
London's financial center it's like a
divorce Britain is set to leave the EU
and both partners have to divide their
belongings and interact differently with
one another lawyers like Rob erred from
the London office of Ashurst are
providing legal advice there are so many
sort of interwoven bits in the fabric of
society I know that the one of the UK's
complaints is oh the year you develop
laws which are just nonsense and okay
there are undoubtedly there are some
areas where it is heavily over
bureaucratic but to actually get a grip
on that task is going to take a long
time and I think most commentators seem
to think between five to ten years to
actually work out Britain remains a
member of the EU for the next two years
if it then leaves new laws would have to
take effect for example in the labor
market EU citizens may require a visa to
work in Britain and Brits may have to
get one to work in the EU when we get to
the end of the our membership as have
already described then there will be
rules put in place around how people can
travel between countries will it mean
that people are rounded up and told to
leave the UK I strongly doubt that but
at the moment we just don't know what
the provision is going to be Britain's
access to the European single market is
another issue up for negotiation many
companies want easy access but what
would have to be done in return the
leave campaign promise to stop sending
money to Brussels there'll be elements
of tax and customs so what does it mean
for a UK exporter in terms of exporting
goods into the EU are there going to be
customs in there you'd like to think not
will there be elements of Product Safety
there'll be rights of access to
financial services
how will banks be able to supply their
products to people with from the UK into
the EU and vice versa greg's its
supporters want Britain to have more
freedom and sovereignty now the country
needs new legislation and it's still
unclear what effects that will have on
the British economy